قلت صحيفه يدع احرنوت عن مصادر امريكيه ان
مقربين من الرئيس الامريكي جو بايدن يخشون
يخشون من مماطله رئيس الوزراء الاسرائيلي
بنيمين نتنياهو في السعي الى صفقه لتبادل
الاسرى من اجل اطاله امد الحرب وتحقيق
مصالح شخصيه
وسياسيه نقلت واشنطن بوست عن مسؤول امريكي
رفيع قوله انه لا جدوى من حث الاسرائيليين
على الانتقال الى المرحله الاقل حده من
الحرب في غزه الشهر الجاري وان واشنطن
اصبحت حاليا تصر على الانتقال الى المرحله
القادمه من الحرب في فبراير القادم بدلا
من الشهر الجاري كما نقلت واشنطن بوست عن
مسؤول اسرائيلي ان العمليه العسكريه في
غزه تنتقل حاليا الى مرحله اقل حده من
الحرب وان عدد الضحايا المدنيين تراجع
بشكل كبير وعلى خلفيه التهم الاسرائيليه
لحماس باستغلال المساعدات الدوليه اكد
المسؤول الامريكي ان الحكومه الاسرائ
لم تقدم اي دليل محدد على قيام حماس بسرقه
او تحويل المساعدات المقدمه عبر الامم
المتحده
ووكالاتها